après avoir enseigné toute la journée
catherine bouvet saint-pierre s'installe
à la table avec la petite juliette pour
l'aider à faire ses devoirs à la cuisine
son conjoint préparent leurs pas et
s'occupe de leur deuxième enfant
catherine beauvais saint pierre est
enseignante depuis dix ans il ya des
enseignants qui abandonnent la
profession
vous vous décidez vous avez décidé de
continuer pourquoi pour l'heure la
petite lueur les l'herbe qui est réussie
l'élève qui te dit à la fin de l'année
il n'aimait pas l'école avant de te
rencontrer pour l'élève qui te dit que
tu lui as donné confiance en lui pour
toutes ces petites victoires là des
petites victoires gagner dans un
contexte difficile
selon vous quel est le mal le plus
importante qui frappe le monde de
l'éducation
je répare pas dit que c'est l'argent le
problème d'argent parce que tout le
reste des problèmes d'après moi découle
de sa manque de ressources matérielles
et de ressources humaines mandailles
pour les élèves des psychologues ça
existe plus dans l'aide dans les
commissions scolaires ou presque le
gendre une fois dans ma vie dans ma
carrière il ya dix ans oui donc qu'ici
on note des élèves qui ont des besoins
psychologie des besoins en orthophonie
des besoins en psychoéducation îles et
les ressources humaines sont l'homme
soit là en quantité insuffisante ou soit
complètement absente
puis on se retrouvait le fardeau de dire
à des parents mais votre enfant
probablement tel problème j'espère que
vous avez l'argent va nous priver
excellent le programme scolaire change
régulièrement à chaque année on nous en
demande plus avec moins donc
personnellement chaque année je me sens
de moins en moins compétentes dans mon
travail parce que j'ai toujours
l'impression d'avoir j'aimerais
s'appelait sur des défis mais des défis
c'est quelque chose qui est motivant
c'est des situations dans lesquelles on
se retrouve où on sent qu'on n'a pas les
outils pour faire notre travail comme il
faut on parle de suis pas en train de
de parler de matériel je parle d'un
enfant le poids de la responsabilité
souvent le milieu nous fait sentir que
se faire poser la question à l'école par
différentes personnes
que ce soit des parents ont des
directions mais a tout fait pour cet
enfant là c'est une question qui est
très courte mais qui est très lourde de
sens où des parents qui nous sommes et
comment vous allez faire pour que mon
enfant réussisse donc la réussite de 25
enfants repose sur mes épaules
j'ai une changer d'école donc cédé
nouveau défilé alors la fatigue
s'installe bon pour x raisons il ya des
moments où on y prie plus épuisés et
j'ai pris une journée de congé chaque
semaine depuis le début de l'année parce
que je veux vraiment mais cette année
c'est ce que je me suis dit je me suis
je le fais pas je n'arriverai pas au
bout
en cette date du début novembre terminer
je n'ai plus de journées de maladie donc
tout ce que je vais prendre journées de
maladie jusqu'à la fin d'année ce sera
mes frais
l'absence en classe fait naître la
culpabilité et ses journées la bête
c'est à dire au moins j'espère qu'ils
ont tout ce dont ils ont besoin ce pas
là le parquet tout se passe bien sans
voile à leurs remplaçants j'espère que
mes collègues sont pris pour me
remplacer
donc c'est ce poids là qu'on a sur les
épaules il est lourd le grand défi pour
survivre sous d'apprendre avant tout des
cauchemars oui ça ça promet que le temps
moi déjà là la catherine de maintenant
versus la première quatrième quart
seignosse a rien à voir ce qu'il ya dix
ans ou quand vous avez commencé votre
carrière
je ne sais pas on peut trouver des
indices en fin de compte oui oh oui oui
on est en gt très idéaliste bagages
avant leur contexte ou s'il n'avait pas
de famille j'avais peur un douzième
heure ont divisé le mot grec est
embarqué au râteau donc j'avais dû tarde
à donner en plus j'en donnais jean
donnet et je me rendais pas compte non
plus peut-être que je m'épuise est ce
que tu t'es parti plus lentement début
je capte plus en forme et je ne sais pas
comment mais alors quoi faire
qu'est ce que vous devez faire pour être
capable de survivre est allé jusqu'à la
vôtre c'est se mettre des limites
faut se mettre des limites il faut
accepter de les dire ses limites là
aussi parce que justement on nous en
demande beaucoup et c'est possible on
m'a donné de dire non je ne peux pas
faire ça - 35 heures tout à fait oui
sûrement parce qu'effectivement je parle
à des collègues qui qui souvent me
disais que me dit peu à peu j'ai appris
à être détachés sais pas c'est pas
facile parce qu'on traite des êtres
humains
ou alors faut-il quitté l'enseignement
je sais aussi ridicule autres je me suis
à passer des tests d'orientation sur
internet voir qu'est-ce que je préfère
d'autres et à la fin ils m'ont écrit
félicitations votre domaine l'éducation
je me dis bon bon s'il faut rester au
moins espérer dans l'immédiat recevoir
l'aide du nouveau gouvernement
mon dieu même de l'argent même de
l'argent et qu'on puisse enfin avoir des
locaux appropriés des écoles qui sont
pas en ruines que les enfants puissent
avoir de l'espace pour travailler la
base pour moi d'une société ça serait
complice est allé à l'école et d'être
bien dans notre école c'est important
pour les aidants enseignants que pour
les forfaits de soukous